you're making it sound like they're in
charge of the house hey tell them to
shut the [ __ ] up where they're gonna
live outside and you're gonna kill the
Easter Bunny that [ __ ] works I never had
those kind of problems just like I never
had the problems with the shitty music
kids listen to you know why my car my
music you don't want to listen to
Hendrix find another ride [ __ ]
you know what I'm saying
no baby shark just say no if he's eating
it you gonna stop that [ __ ] right now
but if he's just picking a winner don't
stop him it's always nice when your kids
get a nice sense of accomplishment
I remember having that problem one word
for you benadryl I remember I used to
fly cross-country with the kids before
we got on the plane I had him so trained
for that benadryl
my oldest son you should say hey Dad
when do we get the juice as soon as we
get on the plane only if he's blowing
the dolls if he's blowing the dolls I
would say for sure he's gay if he's just
playing with the dolls no [ __ ]
questionable might be practicing to get
out of a ticket
because he's a [ __ ] baby every kid is
different I mean look you wouldn't treat
all girls that you were dating the same
right some are like caress my face and
some are like spit in my mouth and poke
my eyes out you're like what the [ __ ]
everyone's different you know is this a
real question is this is this a real
quick
you are the grown-up you don't want them
playing for tonight
take the [ __ ] console out of their
room I don't understand the question the
first thing you do is you be polite and
you let him finish and then you come
back and you tell them from now on
you're washing your own socks and then
you come back you don't do anything he's
gonna jerk off no matter what it doesn't
matter what you do nobody is ready to
have kids that's like asking somebody
you ready to go to prison I don't know
I've never been to prison before you
never did nobody's ready
it's a [ __ ] whoo you know I mean look
they're gotta lie to you well you gotta
be sneaky back you know you can put
something on their phone that tracks
where they are right they were you knew
you know say that's why they invented TV
little-known fact
the person who invented the TV just was
trying to find a way to get his kids to
shut the [ __ ] up there you go
turn it on instant gag well I think the
first thing I would do is I would stop
calling chicks that would be number one
I think this is one of the biggest
conundrums parents go through pretending
that everything our kids say to us it's
so interesting when usually all you hear
in your head is
hey whoa what gave you the idea that any
part of parenting was gonna be easy an
easy way to potty train your kids sure
get somebody else to do it that's pretty
easy that's the one out juice hey your
family should accept you for whoever you
are gay straight doesn't matter that
your family it's your family they should
accept you for whoever you are and if
you try to convince them and it's not
working I would just put it into a show
too and that might work I got one word
for you buddy
benadryl that'll keep those little
[ __ ] asleep for as long as you
want to do that three minutes worth of
work you're gonna do with your wife you
know Sam I mean I guess the first thing
you should try to figure out is why your
son and your girlfriend and you we're
all taking a shower together I mean that
would be question number one for Child
Protective Services I think um who gives
a [ __ ] if your kid gets mad you're the
grown-up put him in the [ __ ] room
until they're not mad anymore you know
I'm saying who cares
ah actually the first time it was pretty
hard man and then um and then we stopped
doing anal and it was a lot easier so
just one man's experience I don't know
how that affects you yeah I would do
what I did man
start telling jokes and lying about how
big your dick is those two seem to work
for me it's a great question man and
something a lot of people go through
right I think the best move is to talk
to them like a real person and say we're
gonna be here together we can either do
it easy or hard and if that doesn't work
just lean in and go [ __ ] your mom see if
that works well man I would just like to
hear it straight up you know but if my
son told me he was doing weed I'd
probably laugh in his face cuz clearly
if you say you're doing weed you're not
doing it well I remember when my son
started taking long showers I told him I
don't want to tell you I know it's
in there but I know it's happening in
there and from now on you clean the
drain you filthy animal you know that
[ __ ] sticks to the hair and the drain it
makes like a beaver dam I got to tell
you something the diaper thing will
solve itself nobody wants to go into
kindergarten with [ __ ] into the pants I
promise you that the breastfeeding thing
what's too old what isn't too old I mean
there's definitely age like you
shouldn't be squirting your mom's milk
in your latte that's probably too old I
mean that totally depends how dirty is
your house I mean if you need that [ __ ]
cleaned I would I would go with the meth
however if you would like your TV to be
there when you wake up I would just use
the ibuprofen I must say right now only
an animal wipes back to front I don't
know about women but if you're wiping
back to front you have dirty nuts
there's no getting around it you may not
have [ __ ] on your nuts but you got some
dusty dirty ass nuts say what now how
does your nine year old even know where
to look for porn or what it is second of
all I blame you man you gotta clean up
those Google searches so he's just not
clicking on them and you don't want to
tell your wife cuz then your wife will
know what porn you're into although I
don't have young kids so I really don't
know what either one of those are
however I do believe I've seen the porn
doc mcstuffins and it is a doozy wait
till he gets that stethoscope out watch
out next say what now
I mean what he doesn't know tonight the
good news is is that he'll never get
anyone pregnant
cuz nobody's ever gonna see his dick say
what now Oh poop sock
your son shits in a sock so come on I'm
not mean explanation I don't know man
you know there's always a chance he
feels the same way
man what you're supposed to do tell her
she to have a good time and you trust
her and you know you can call at any
time and don't drink and drive and make
sure you check her purse for the clothes
that she's really gonna wear on the date
not the ones she leaves the house in
you need to get [ __ ] under control in
your house why does your son think it's
okay to take his dick out in the living
room that's my question what what the
[ __ ] is a poops sock this is like the
third time do you all let your kids [ __ ]
in a sock what the [ __ ] is happening out
there